Tom Holland is a highlight of every
movie He's a Part of even when things
don't go as planned these are the
bloopers that prove he's just as
charismatic when he's out of character
superhero films have a lot of action as
well plenty of it may be computer
generated there's still a lot the actors
have to do themselves with all the
endless jumps kicks and flips required
of a Spider-Man performance there are
bound to be a few times when an actor
loses their balance in Tom Holland's
second Spider-Man movie Spider-Man far
from home Holland's Peter Parker and
Jake Gyllenhaal's Quinton Beck AKA
Mysterio battle against a monster called
the fire Elemental as a carnival in
Prague that's heinous monster is later
revealed to be a projection manipulated
by Beck and a special effects team but
at the time Peter doesn't know it after
faking a heroic sacrifice to defeat the
monster Beck lies on the ground and
Peter jumps down from the ferris wheel
to check on his unlikely companion when
filming one take of this scene Holland's
balancing skills proved a little less
than graceful though he could have
chosen to break character Holland
ultimately rolled with her and made his
way over into Gyllenhaal's waiting arms
Tony Stark meant a lot to Peter Parker
and his grief over Stark's death in
Avengers end game is a prominent
emotional threat of Spider-Man far from
home a major moment comes when Peter
gives the glasses a stark bequeathed him
to back feeling unworthy to carry on the
legacy of Iron Man it's my choice to
make okay and I'm gonna make it look
you're a soldier a leader you stop the
Elementals you saved my life you saved
the world this heartbreaking plot beat
showcases how Peter is struggling with
his insecurities and pain after losing
yet another father figure but you
wouldn't know any of that from watching
the outtakes despite the scene being
such an emotional moment Holland
couldn't keep from losing his composure
take after take after a few failed
attempts and unable to keep from
laughing Holland finally asked the crew
for a way out of his predicament can you
this Workshop the scene in a few
different ways each try ended with
Holland and fits of laughter so next
time you watch that tear-jerking Pub
scene just remember Holland was fighting
back tears just not from sadness
since Spider-Man far from home is
centered around Peter Parker and his
classmates taking a field trip to
another continent it only makes sense
that some of the movie had to be filmed
on location in Europe when shooting in
Venice Italy it seems that the beautiful
scenery may have been a little too
breathtaking for the actors to keep
their focus Peter and Jacob bartolom's
Ned stood silently for a little bit
longer than anticipated during a take
and Holland had to take the scene by the
horns directed by Tom Holland does a
pretty nice ring to it wouldn't you say
that's when you say you're lying Jacob
you say it first there you go what's
going on is it for is it me first
a lot of strength training goes into
being a Marvel Star as effortless as the
actors and stun performers make their
abilities look on screen a lot of
intense preparation is needed for Action
stars to become world famous superheroes
and sometimes it's still not enough the
10th climactic Battle of Spider-Man far
from home comes when Peter faces his
fears and steps up to challenge Mysterio
on the London Bridge while Peter was
challenging Beck's Authority on the set
Holland's challenge Gillen Hall to
something else a push-up contest the
pair made it at least a 20 though
Gyllenhaal Tapped Out spidey sense and
arm strength Tom Holland just keeps
winning
Captain America Civil War had a lot of
moving Parts including the MCU debuts
for Chadwick boseman's Black Panther and
Tom Holland Spider-Man the first time we
see Peter Parker in the MCU Tony Stark
makes a surprise visit to his apartment
chatting with Aunt May as Peter arrives
home from school the two have never met
before Stark is a popular billionaire
superhero and Peter is a high school
student naturally Peter is nervous and
it turns out Holland might have been as
well
um
not Tony it's not like we can blame him
though this is the first time audiences
will see you as one of Marvel's most
iconic superheroes and your first
seniors of the originator of the MCU
itself that's some serious pressure and
a great responsibility and speaking of
responsibility
some Holland doesn't deal with every
onset mishap the same way sometimes he
remains firmly in character even while
funny stuff and follows around him other
times he breaks character on purpose for
the sake of a job to give the crew a
laugh this next blooper is an example of
the latter in 2017 Spider-Man homecoming
Peter School decathlon team is about to
head to a tournament in Washington DC
trying to find a way out of the
commitment so he can take on more
Spider-Man duties he covers for his
absence by saying he's in a stark
internship on the sets Holland delivered
his line with some added Flair and my
internship you know I got a lot of
responsibility with it
with great power it comes great
responsibility well that's like guarding
Spidey line would eventually make its
way into Holland's version of Spider-Man
it would have to wait four more years
and a whole lot of trauma for it to
become canon in the MCU
in every on-screen version of Peter
Parker's story Aunt May has been a
parental figure to him this of course is
due to the absence of Peter's parents
out of the eight main live-action
Spider-Man movies you've seen over the
past two decades Andrew Garfield's two
Amazing Spider-Man movies provided the
most thorough backstory about what
happened to Peter's mom and dad
meanwhile the Tom Holland Trilogy
doesn't mention them at all and if they
did would probably assume the situation
would be addressed with a seriousness it
deserves so it comes as somewhat of a
shock for Holland to casually reference
Peter's parents in the middle of a
gruesome joke while filming Spider-Man
homecoming when Peter arrives at an epic
party hosted by Laura harrier's
character Liz he remarks how cool it is
that her parents let her throw such an
amazing night when filming Holland
fumbled through the scenes a few times
apparently having a hard time getting
the line right in one take he found
himself improvising a follow-up sentence
my parents are dead
before they teamed up as Spider-Man and
dogged a strange in the MCU Tom Holland
and Benedict Cumberbatch star together
in the current War a historical drama
about the dawn of electricity in the
United States Cumberbatch played the
inventor of the light bulb himself
Thomas Edison or Holland played Samuel
Insel one of Edison's business
associates while the audio is spotty
footage from an unlocation shoot for the
film shows Holland and Cumberbatch hug
while Holland appears to crack a joke we
might never know what builds up to the
punch line but we're 100 positive it had
to have been the world's funniest joke
it's hard to say if Holland and
Cumberbatch knew while filming the
current war that they would soon share
scenes in Avengers Infinity war and
co-star together as main cast members in
Spider-Man no way home nevertheless
they'd already made their MCU debuts by
the current war and their established
Rapport as members of the Marvel family
was pretty evident
as part of the promotional campaign for
2021 Spider-Man no way home Poland and
batalan filmed a Hyundai commercial as
Peter Parker and Ned Leeds there are
many questions that go unanswered in
this commercial like why Peter is even
there but there were also some bloopers
when filming after hopping in Ned's car
Peter asks a simple question but the
green screen shoot seems to have made
him skip an important step what are we
gonna do for 300 miles
we're gonna put our seat belts on oh
that's right
whoops click it on ticket Parker
there's a tense moment in 2018's
Avengers Infinity War when Chris Pratt's
Star-Lord grabbed Spider-Man pressing a
blaster to his face having just arrived
on thanos's home planet Tyson each
character thinks the other is working
for the big bad instead of assuming
they're all on the same team though this
could have been a very suspenseful Scene
It has ultimately played for Laughs as
the heroes entangle their confusion yeah
oh do you wonder why I'm better who's
Gamora I'll do you one better why is
Gamora and the filming had an even loose
atmosphere than that
who are you guys
[Music]
this blooper is made even better because
it's a reminder that Holland's wrong
motion capture suits anytime Peter
Parker done the iron spider armor this
allowed special effects artists the
ability to bring Stark's nanotech to
life in post-production by tracking
Holland's movements with what was
mounted by his suit so the next time you
watch Spider-Man swinging to battle on
Titan just imagine Tom Holland's doing
all of that in a gray onesie with
triangles all over him
arguably one of the most epic moments of
the whole Marvel Cinematic Universe
comes in 2019's Avengers end game as the
largest group of Marvel Superheroes ever
gathers together to fight Thanos for The
Infinity Gauntlet just before charging
forward into battle dozens of iconic
characters played by dozens of
Hollywood's biggest movie stars strike
their dramatic poses many people can
probably remember the chills they had in
the moment when Captain America declares
for the first and so far only time in
the MCU
Avengers
assemble considering how iconic this
moments had to be the actors knew they
had to get it right on sets as everyone
took their marks moments before the
scene was shot Pratt rallied everyone
for their big moment nobody pull a
hamstring
the break into a bit of laughter when a
crew member called for everyone to get
in position he immediately logged into
Peter Parker's game phase faster than a
Thanos snap impressive
sometimes it's almost impossible to get
a decent take when shooting a movie or
television show well there was the long
hours inside jokes or both sometimes
everything is funny for no reason and
the actors can't get it together that
was certainly the case for Holland and
Gyllenhaal at least once on the set of
Spider-Man far from home the scene in
question is simple enough Peter Parker
meets Quinton Beck for the first time
and the two characters shake hands easy
right wrong in the release blooper
footage Holland started a long string of
flood takes by laughing and only got
worse when the director suggested a
change I'll be a tiny bit closer
but in the next take Dylan Hall broke
first proving the laughter was
infectious
usable take drifted so far that one had
Holland and Gyllenhaal interlocking
their arms while eating watermelon the
finished shot did manage to make it into
the movie Blue for free so we know they
eventually held it together long enough
for a simple handshake sympathy to
director John Watts for the unexpected
hard time
[Music]
thank you